walking into this video yeah always have
to love when I play this guy a rapper
Blanca that's a funny handle so the
classical Kings Indian playing the
bionet how can you play this so quickly
really I mean not a criticism I mean
just technically how how can you do that
um some people are just blazingly fast
can i play G form to sort of close the
King side let me try that I'm not a big
fan of this super tough race situation
so trying to to get my my king out of it
so the shop here be sure to to e1 ok
they should have taken I should have
taken now we can take with the bishop
hmm ok he doesn't me okay it's not clear
that this was so brilliant taking with
the bishop but it certainly came into
consideration
check okay
okay I'm it looks like i'm relatively
safe there the night to f2 would be
definitely helpful to secure this even
more I'm wondering if I can do something
in that regard Queen you one quickly one
maybe so checking on h4 I don't really
think I'm threatening to take it but I'm
also trying to make night d 1 f 2
possible okay let's let's do this
maneuver looks somewhat artificial
button dead least secure us in my
position ok here hope you should be five
maybe this is an idea it looks really
artificial but I don't want to fall
super far behind on the clock headers
always some some tricks bound to happen
in this kind of Kings Indian structures
those pieces look weird but I hope they
they rotate the ridge item and looks is
seven or not yeah probably
k back so now there there are some some
sort of weaknesses and I can take age
seven right night or just I can I can
advance them oh true now he attacks my
porn
okay yeah well it was clear that I'm not
like clearly better or something but
that was a good defense it's h3 a threat
might be cannot take here
I wasn't sure maybe we can just play age
three yeah but I i don't really i can go
all the way to g3 but i don't knowi know
if this is doing that much i am i
overlooking a tactic Bishop g4 is the
tactic for f3 no that's not on ok ok
just he just wants to enter them and say
that this is this is the the big thing
here ok i can go knight c6 in this
position but for i can go rook c8
he's got Bishop to b6 very dangerous I
guess I have to go for a quick Queen to
you one now if it's not too late already
this is all this is very dangerous trick
checking Bishop to b6 well I completely
I'd only now see that you can go to be
six very bad time morning very bad I
don't I don't see a defense to that to
be honest i mean this this is only
installing stalling things be 54 B
should be six
just hoping for Bishop b6 roop c5 which
probably had probably learn it will lead
to nothing but ok let's just try to go
for some checks oh this this is also
this is also on yeah that that that was
a problem wait I can go here but rook c8
ok now he played he played this really
right resides that looked like a well
played game ah let's see him I think I
should be ok around here but some
somewhere in this vicinity somewhere
around here Joker took yeah b5 is given
by the engine yeah I'm probably one
thing is that if I do this and we have
this kind of trade I have lights afford
to cover the v6 square here yeah now
aged 3 is strong I didn't see Bishop to
b6 I mean I saw that he enters with the
queen but I thought I can I can cover it
but it's really it's really absolutely
lost track this kind of thing totally
lost we should be 6 s deadly gathered
that you played really well I have to
have to do something I mean probably ok
up to here and have to improve improve
in this position this shouldn't be
shouldn't be terrible I think I'm a
skeptical in those closed position about
computer evaluation stock fishin gives
me a pretty pretty sizable advantage but
I don't I don't know about that I don't
really know because well the dark
squared Bishop is probably coming into
game somehow and then all my king and
Kings 95 this is the stock fish line and
nights if Roy had this yeah this could
be better for white even even if you say
the computer is not great in this type
of position this is probably really
better for my jam I'm always attacking d
sexy cannot go Bishop v6 and I'm ready
to trade this active night off yeah what
is better him it really is true but the
way I played I wasn't better now nicely
played ok thanks for watching